all right so let's start with you Milo
why did you think aloud a transgender
student for ridicule during a recent
speech you made on her campus did you do
that well yes
first of all wasn't a student he had
already left the university and I make
no apologies for protecting women and
children I'm going to and were confused
about their sexuality I'm going to use
what who this is because pronouns are so
important if you call Caitlyn Jenner he
or a bad person yeah I didn't happen you
did so this is a man I mean gendered
yeah right person right so this is a man
born man who wants thinks that he might
be a girl okay and another problem with
that no I don't have a problem with it
but I think that women and change and
girls should be protected from having
people men who were confused about their
sexual identities in their bathroom that
person that's not an unreasonable person
you know was a you know an activist who
took their own university to court to
force his way into the change that the
female locker rooms had already left
college by the time I gave that speech
and that was totally misrepresented
reported by the press just like they
were miserable everything back where do
you stand on weirdos pillow sounds like
you just called it I look at the people
weirdos justify him I think you two are
doing a great job with this topic
I don't really know anything either I
think it like that because we're same
arguments that we used against gay
people treating them like aliens who
just wanted to [ __ ] anything that moved
and I we should avoid them at all no no
I think the biggest let me finish myself
please um you know there there's there's
a difference without a distinction
because you're using the same type of
arguments it's like when people try to
compare a gay and black yeah they're not
the same thing we share an invisibility
you know people didn't see us in society
and gay people hidden hid out from
society right there were a lot of the
same issues that you have to deal with
when you're marginalized
we own it now so that discriminates a
group that are marginalized and so the
attack you can always find an extreme
person that becomes the object of your
attack to assign that to everybody so if
you say well that person is weird or
they want to do commit sexual assault
and everybody thinks all transgender
people want to do is commit sexual
assault
well they aren't disproportionately
involved in a crime there what vastly
disproportionately involved in sex crime
who is under yes we call it I don't
think that's not it's not a
controversial statistic and it you know
actually this isn't frankly you know
you're saying you're suggesting these
people the victims of some kind of
discrimination well I'm saying to you
this is a this is a psychiatric disorder
I didn't like women age like you did a
psychiatric I say what are July like not
like identity disorder or like
sociopathy or something you know I you
know people around little girls involved
I'm saying Kara what I'm saying I'm sure
I said this is why I said the same
argument we used against gay people you
should do your homework because it's
wrong than it does right now that's
preferably no helmet sexuality was
called a disorder it was a psychological
disorder is are you aware disorder well
maybe maybe you are maybe it is but most
homosexuals are not you know what now I
think in this case most days have a long
road
I think I mean I boast gays have a long
road to coming to terms with the
sexuality and their because of them
handy highway teaching of course it
isn't that we know of course it so
everybody can see the Society for Mike
we're fine with gay people it's 1890 you
think in 1990 people getting up being
very excused if I know I'm cute mmm I
another question I love ya if I called
you the chocolate all I know is it one
quick question I'm not a journalist
and I may just be an old spy but you
would if you were talking about
confusion were we talking about you what
because you sounds very confusion we're
talking about people being confused
about their sexuality to know in the
world how long you know I mean I've been
the ports I eat in Naples and you look
like you've been there a few times
what are because you seem to be very
clear about what you are what you want
out there huh yeah all right shipmate
Sadie always have to fight with
everybody
oh you want to get a long time but you
want such awful people and your sugars
are so stupid no come on unitary
although inviting higher IQ guarantee
the dog first of all these are very you
go [ __ ] yourself all right
yeah
Oh
[Applause]
your argument is that these people is
stupid you didn't hear a word this man
said early in this segment because he
can talk circles around your eyes setec
siscon she little ass
[Applause]
laughing I don't you depends I'll let
you defend it Leslie Jones is not very
literate
go [ __ ] yourself again for that he can
barely spell it Larry
I'm a great fan of yours man I'm
grabbing your we are all about the First
Amendment here in my life for brother
because I think what they did to you and
Berkeley was I talk about strange better
no handsome that would it be strange but
we didn't look because I would make it
you already take it as Puckle
but no carelessness weeds white so I say
no but I know you make a beautiful
couple
shut up for one [ __ ] second really I
mean look this is the beginning of your
career people are only just starting to
hate you I've got too many voices and
the way I'm just saying
yet you have the potential to morph I
mean you remind me like of a young gay
alive Christopher Hitchens yeah that's
what you got to lose that kind of [ __ ]
by telling Walter telling to get well
they're getting sued this guy this guy
hadn't done the things that allowed you
to [ __ ] live
[Applause]
I don't know where that well I do know
Malcolm very well Malcolm and I have
debated many times we have become
friends the four of us are going to go
out and buy beer together right
Republicans with our magic are will pay
for it okay I don't think it is unlikely
I wanted just one quick question yes are
you the real true face to the all right
because I thought the Nazis were in
there how do they take you on board I
know this is one of the enduring
mysteries of American media with mr.
Whitman being a anti-semitic white
supremacist hateful bigoted racist
homophobic movement and gauge world
never shuts up as black Boykin is the
head of it something's not quite right
you know that's not all your fans some
of them are your they hate me they hate
me I'm saying this is I like you well
you're always welcome media doesn't
report your van your DOMA hates me they
declared holy war gisli the worst people
in a very far left and the very very far
right all hailing they all hate me okay
I think we're leaving outta luck you're
welcome
[Applause]
bertalanffy
I think big toggle of how human could
bring people together congressman Jack
Kingston I don't want a question I'm
just gonna clear what happens of voter
fraud have you seen that leads you to
believe Donald Trump's claims yeah
Donald yeah and that guy we showed
Stephen Miller said I will corroborate
the president percent 2 to 3 million
people voted illegally I mean this is
one of those all facts that has been
disproved there have not been anywhere
near these kind of amounts of people who
voted illegally you know you're not
really on that train are you there are
some concerns
one point I noticed people who are dead
or registered to vote why did that me
not anything done the same thing we're
talking about in-person voter fraud I
heard if people on the rolls who are
dead are not showing up to vote
that's what yes they are of them are no
no no this chemical give me some other
oh okay there are 20 million people who
are improperly registered and we're
concern about that that the general team
classes of India coding fraud ninety
five percent or three of them were Trump
loaders trying to prove there was voting
the only or even Texas telling voter
fraud the only voter fraud was getting
the American people to believe the false
equivalency bit Hillary and Trump were
of equal horribleness
right hey wait and that's Olivia i
greased out liberal he was I worse
okay flattering running from hand is the
gaze well taking money from Saudi Arabia
I'll take Trump any [ __ ] day wait
you'll take Russia's flies over Saudis
okay thanks
what I probably would are you American
no now we're good
I mean aren't you know it's awful day I
don't know I got you out of three I got
a to edit I got two out of three go [ __ ]
yourselves I've got one more come on
what are we just agree I'm gonna happen
what do we do something I need to get a
cookie all right all right all right go
[ __ ] you shut up Larry should Canadians
agree to perform at the White House
Correspondents Dinner this is a big
controversy I'm so [ __ ] littly are you
kidding me I mean I was reading your
question I know what are you saying yes
no bill I mean this is to go along with
the whole free speech thing what an
opportunity you have Donald Trump the
president there Donald juninho right I
mean you have the opportunity to stand
right next to him and write comedy
you're gonna give that out it was a
comedy at that event that made him run
for president ya know there's a lot of
rich irony in it you know there is I
don't care who the comedian is if you're
asked to do that
do not turn that down it's a great
opportunity okay Michael what do you
think the relationship is between
WikiLeaks and the Trump administration
well first off for everyone who really
thinks WikiLeaks is this you know free
spirited you know transparency
organization you can just put that to
bed they are a laundromat for Russian
intelligence they were the conduit for
all of the stolen emails and they were
pretty open about it now what's really
funny about this is when I wrote this in
my book for the number of emails that
were hacked stolen all the voicemails
everything for ten months was stolen
from the DNC and then all these other
things I've done operations of a similar
size it would take three hundred people
working twelve ones or 24 hour shifts
three eight three eight-hour watch
shifts to analyze all that data and then
they were doing these precision data
dumps Trump would talk about
Pennsylvania within 96 hours every email
about Pennsylvania that had ever been
sent to the DNC was released
this was a 100 pound guy in his bedroom
no with 300 drunk-ass Russian guys in
their bedroom actually working in an
operation center human intelligence
officers political warfare officers a
massive effort had to take on during the
day and say make their computers a
little more secure
well you know he is a private entity
like the RNC so the RNC was smart enough
not I can you can unleash it let me
explain these very words I work hard at
you we want to generate the resources to
you we will get into your system the
Russians just decided they were working
for you how do you
[Music]
for Ronald Reagan to tear down the wall
the big enemy Russia now they're your
friend not the party over country that's
how very bizarre
[Applause]